we
are amazing welcome to
to the uh father's day youtube live i'm
jessalyn peterson
apologize for the late start but we are
black and black people are late
we start on cp time i'm glad you're here
you love me
i don't really know you do you have to
know me to love me yeah well i love you
thank you are you surprised not really
were you surprised that i threw you off
the radio show
not really and one of the reasons i'm
concerned about you being a progressive
is that me specifically or all
progressives all men
men only men only men progressive women
don't concern
it's normal normal abnormal for women to
be progressive
interesting or liberal but it's abnormal
for a man to be
a liberal or progressive is a sign of
being a beta male
i didn't know because real men are
conservative
if i became conservative would i no
longer be beta
you become alpha well something to think
about
do you find that it's difficult for
young men maybe your age group
to find good women to date not at all
all right why don't you date men i'm not
attracted to men oh good
but what you consider it might be a man
would you think of it as a man
it would i think of it as a man right
it's a person right i don't say right
it's a female the children of a lot of
the liberal media
the democratic party the writer
republicans the double trumpers
okay uh so like everybody but trump the
hashtag
movement plus you sound mentally off you
know like
like the likes was all but nobody was
home you're making assessments of who's
mentally off on
tv but that's how evil the children on
the left are they'll destroy you
to get what they want and that's power
and wealth i'm curious if they're so
powerful
the children of the law but they're not
powerful oh i should tell you
that's what they want i think they will
destroy you they will they'll destroy
you they'll try to destroy you oh okay
you get power
do you agree with that no no we're
bringing that up the reason was you've
called me a girly man so many times
remember we talked about that oh okay
that's because it's not because i think
you
that i'm gay right got it glad we
clarified you know a lot of people are
sexually assaulted and raped
and they don't come forward and the
reason they don't commit
you don't believe that that's a made-up
lie too oh who made that up the children
are the laughs oh i should have
the children of their lives i should
have known they're doing it because they
hate men
oh and they especially hate straight
white conservative christian men of
power
if it wasn't for them america would be
associated with society already it would
be what a socialist
[Music]
society
[Applause]
if you're thinking about joining the
david
backman show he's got a lot of
content don't you know
search a subject but don't forget to
add his name at the end of the subject
[Music]
he'll hit you with some facts
empirical at that
and once or twice a week he'll mention
about
his gardens pretty good garden now but
it's not for everyone
you should also know
that there is a bonus show
producer pat will give his take which is
a pretty
decent perspective pat knows what he's
talking about
if you're thinking about joining the
david
pacman show he's got lots of
content don't you know
search a subject but don't forget to add
his name
at the end of the subject if you're
thinking about
joining the david pacman show
he's got lots of content don't you know
search a subject but don't forget to
add his name at the end of the search
criteria
all right welcome everybody we are live
and uh rudy giuliani has been suspended
as a lawyer in the state of new york
it's all incredible and it is the first
stream
with the new studio computer you know as
as some of you remember we have had many
a stream
either that never happened
or that got cut short because of windows
updates
on a computer without a solid state
drive and
as part of my commitment for that not to
happen
we have a new studio computer and uh
it's not
not everything yet is correct so we're
gonna work through some of the things
like for example
the super chats are not aligned oh and
my mouse is visible mouse is not
supposed to be
oh there's a super chat okay good now
it's an opportunity to actually line
these up correctly so let me see if i
can do it
uh so we're gonna move this and then
we'll move this over here
and then we can even expand
so i think we got that and then let's
see if we go over to
our other shot here
[Music]
pretty close actually let's see if we
could just do a really small adjustment
here and maybe move over you can
you kind of have to do this stuff as the
super chats come in
so i think we got that
okay good excellent so um
i am building up our repertoire of div
so let me tell people what we have now i
i've been
talking about how i've been holding off
on programming my stream deck
fully until i'm on the new computer
because
otherwise it would all be you know
i would have to redo everything so what
i've got programmed now
are you know we've got our three basic
shots here i've done a small adjustment
to the audio
offset so i believe my i had to do 100
milliseconds and now my voice
should be synced to the video
that's looking pretty pretty close maybe
off by 15 or 20.
and then um what else do we have
uh i did set up websites i frequently
use i can now pull up with the touch of
a button so if i say oh
you know sir what's going on on twitter
i can just pull up my twitter with the
touch of a button
we've got the live uh pacman live
counter
i can pull that up easily if i had like
a tick tocks issue
oh hold on websites i can pull up tick
tocks right away
we've got the show's instagram we've got
my instagram
you know all these things i think are
really good to have if ever someone had
a question about membership which really
never happens it's so straightforward
i can pull up the membership page so
we've got all of that stuff let me let
me now close these things out
um close close close actually you know
what
we probably want to keep this up live
just because that that may be something
that we need a little bit later
so all of that stuff is going um and
then what else did i set up and then
otherwise i just have my various intros
which you heard
um at the beginning and then also i have
so many audio files now so now is the
time to get your clean audio drops into
me someone sent me a bunch of really
good ones
for music we just have ymca
okay so we just have that then i have a
a couple biden ones i've got this come
on man
and then i've also got will you shoot
okay so that's it for biden stuff right
now under miscellaneous
i have bernie yeah good he's treated
okay yeah good okay yeah good
it's treated okay you never know when
you're gonna need that and then these
are very very topical
oh no sam cedar sam who
sam who so that we have on the biden
and miscellaneous and then the trump
stuff is just completely off the rails
people sent me so much amazing stuff
so first of all i have a whole dumps
folder
big massive dumps dumps they call them
dumps
so we've got the dumps folder sir is
almost completely full
congratulations sir you just won the
election
mr president sir mr president sir
how are you on the cover of time
magazine again sir i think you're doing
very well
sir i don't know sir you can't ask that
question sir
sir i don't even know what i'm doing sir
sir your wife is up in the air sir he's
better than i am
okay so we've got a whole bunch of sur
stuff china is a folder
china all the time china
china china okay so we've got that
um and then just miscellaneous things
that that might be relevant at any time
stand back and stand by we've got the
extortion
i need 11 000 votes give me a break
bathroom stuff
elements of bathrooms elements of them
and then we fell in love okay but that
was a good one
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
and god bless the united states
that one the quality is a little low if
someone could redo that one for me with
a higher uh
higher quality source that would be good
and then just a couple of others
looking at that very strongly the noise
causes cancer
i don't care what they name it name it
peaches
and then lastly we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers
i just love that bathrooms and flushing
and and showers people are flushing
toilets ten times fifty
looking very strongly at sinks and
showers okay so that's basically that's
basically everything i have currently on
my stream deck
so get your stuff in okay get your stuff
in because we can add these just have to
keep everything organized
okay very good and if anything else
seems out you know not not properly
configured for today's stream let me
know but the big news is
new studio computer and many many
elements that are important
i do want to say thanks before we get
into the rudy stuff to josh rambo
as well as indiana bob
zabooza weslow
and uh is that everybody oh hold on i've
got to turn off
followers yeah hold on let me go back to
the beginning it's just
indiana bob weslow and mini chopper for
me
have signed up via twitch and i really
appreciate that and also want to say
thank you to
marcy irby hollins who just signed up on
my website
and marcus williams just signed up on my
website the coupon code
cold feet crowder is done
after this week we are of course
celebrating the incredible thing that
happened this week
oh no sam cedar and uh big big
confrontation there
sam who yeah i don't know who that was
but some sam out of nowhere
and another important thing is that we
just put together this video and this i
think is absolutely fascinating
producer pat um legitimately
actually came to me earlier this week
and he wanted to talk to me and he said
i don't even know what i'm doing sir and
i said pat you do know what you're doing
let's put together this video of a
variety of different debates
and let's capitalize on what's going on
with sam and steven crowder so we're
just going to look at a little bit of
this but these are just
some miscellaneous examples of debates
and uh this is a great shareable video
okay let's check this out vegetarianism
is one of the biggest things that i have
a problem with
due to my my my family history being i
know it's kind of a meme but mixed
and this comes from when we look at
affirmative time isn't that identity
politics you're saying your view on this
is informed you're against identity
politics
as informed by your identity
yeah it it it is what it is the aclu
when they supported affirmative action
at harvard which lumps all asians indian
chinese laotians into one category and i
find that offensive as an asian person
and so when i come out and say tim tim
that's an identity
to say you should be able to argue
whether it's offensive or not offensive
right or not right
without saying because you are part
asian you fight like
that's identity politics which you claim
to be against i no i agree i think i
think the clarification then i think
what we're discovering here
is that it's not so much the core idea
of identity politics it's the
application of
in ways that either is reductive or
authoritarian everything you're building
here right now right
do you want the government to tell you
how to do all these things and all the
regulations that you got to have your
electric thing this far from this and
like all that the regulations like that
for construction are important though
you do have to make sure that people
don't do stupid [ __ ]
but make sure you don't have a power
lines near a water line
there's a lot of but i would put most of
that on the builders though they want to
build things that are good now i get
high
oh that's not true listen people don't
know people are going to corners
all the time like you have to have
regulations when it comes to
construction methods or people are going
to get [ __ ]
they cut regulate they cut corners when
there are regulations so anyway we did
this pat did a great job with this turn
this around in like a day and a half
we've got chapters it's very very
shareable um
this is a great sam cedar moment that
made it in i just want to live on my
land and be completely self-sufficient
and not pay your taxes after three years
the town would come
kick you off of your property and seize
your land how would you know it's your
land
how would you prove that it's your land
well in theory you would have a property
deed because that's what happens when
you buy property
who would issue the property deal you
get a d
well right now there are governments
that issue those things
and what i'm saying is we're talking
about the current paradigm
of how could you own land and there are
things
right now that exist when you go buy
land you get a deed
for the land right if you're talking
about what would happen at a free
society then there would be
competing agencies probably that would
issue such
needs which one would you you're asking
me to centrally plan
liberty and that's not what i'm
interested in what i'm interested in
wait a second i want to hear about that
right hold on sam
okay so that was a really good one let's
just pick like
just one other random thing here uh
there's a bunch of really good examples
we have marianne me and jesse
andrew neal and shapiro rogan and
candace
this is a good one here what i'm trying
to talk about is the totality of
evidence that he's mishandled this
pandemic and it's interesting to me that
you were extremely unwilling to
criticize him for that
because what's the alternative the
alternative what would have happened in
any other circumstance where we have no
we have no control group
what am i supposed to say so well wait
right how many would have flipped how
many
how many would have had to have died
before you would criticize him
i don't know give me you don't know wait
so you could have let a million
so what you're telling me is that we
have no idea what would have happened if
trump did anything else we don't ever
suppose
we don't determine that's you're you're
making a tautological statement that's
how the universe works we don't ever
know what would happen
what am i supposed to say when fouchy
early on praise that when governors
early on praised him
now they're critical of him in an
election not oh wait wait first of all
the praise of governors is irrelevant
our governor's health experts second of
all
fauci praised him a couple of times he's
also under a lot of political pressure
to do what trump says or otherwise
there's a very
decent chance of him getting canned uh
fauci has made plenty of statements
which trump has later contradicted
trump has been back and forth on the
mask issue going so far as to make fun
of people for where he is
you claim to have like this um a
disaffected
sort of like anti-establishment view of
all of this but you are your channel is
hyper partisan
against the left and then when anyone
criticizes trump you'll either defend
him harshly or you'll back up and say
well they're all bad
you are taking the choice to defend
trump you are the partisan here
you're not a distanced
anti-authoritarian you are standing with
him and you are saying yes
i am anti-authoritarian i am
anti-establishment but also
we don't know if him lying to the
american people was bad it could have
caused a panic
so anyway this is a clip called here's
why the right is afraid to debate the
left
i posted the link to to the twitch chat
as well as to the youtube chat
but this would be a great one to share
and a lot of our various friends appear
in this one
and of course the culmination of it at
the end is what happened
um this week with sam cedar and stephen
crowder and that's a really good one
oh no sam cedar sam who
sam who right so that's the new video
wanted to go over that with you guys
just briefly
uh but let's now get into what's going
on with rudy giuliani
whoa no i don't want whatever this is
i'm opting out rudy giuliani
suspended from practicing law
in new york state rudy giuliani the
former personal lawyer for president
trump
who once held one of the legal
profession's most prestigious jobs
what job is that was suspended thursday
from practicing law
in new york state by an appellate court
that found he make quote demonstrably
false and misleading statements about
the 2020 election
he also gave people covet at the
hearings and farted uncontrollably but i
guess that's not legally relevant
in a ruling released following
disciplinary proceedings the court
concluded that there is uncontroverted
evidence
that rudy giuliani the former manhattan
u.s attorney
communicated demonstrably false and
misleading statements to courts
lawmakers and the public at large in his
capacity as lawyer
for former president donald j trump and
the trump campaign
in connection with trump's failed effort
at re-election in 2020.
giuliani's conduct immediately threatens
the public interest
and warrants interim suspension from the
practice of
law the suspension of his law license
marks a precipitous fall
for the former new york city mayor once
considered an up
accomplished and formidable force in
legal circles
in recent years however giuliani's
reputation has suffered that's an
understatement
as he has come under criminal
investigation
by the office he used to lead the
manhattan u.s attorney's office
for possible illegal lobbying no illegal
discounts just illegal lobbying
he has denied wrongdoing giuliani's
lawyers because remember maga means
making attorneys get attorneys
giuliani's lawyers john leventhal and
barry caymans
said in a statement thursday that they
are disappointed with the appellate
division
decision suspending giuliani prior to
being afforded a hearing on the issues
they
that are alleged this is unprecedented
they say as we believe our client does
not pose a present danger to the public
interest
oh yes he does have you seen him passing
gas in public and he he
could have possibly given jenna ellis
coveted by gas
that is a that's a present danger if
i've ever seen one we believe that once
the issues are fully explored at a
hearing giuliani will be reinstated as a
valued member of the legal profession
that he has served so well in his many
capacities
for so many years um
cnn senior legal analyst ellie hoenig
said suspensions are like this are
unusual
you're a lawyer your job is to jealously
represent your client a lot of times
your client maybe has done wrong but
what you cannot do as a lawyer is just
lie
this doesn't happen every day by any
stretch this is a very rare thing
and a very extreme thing for the court
to do
rudy set to appear in court in dc
thursday
for proceedings in a defamation lawsuit
so that's what's going on with rudy
giuliani
it's bad enough when your lawyer has to
get a lawyer it's even worse when your
lawyer is suspended from being a lawyer
uh that that's pretty bad that's pretty
bad and we have some video
uh let me see where i can get these here
here's some follow-ups this is uh this
is really
this is andrew giuliani who's running
for governor of new york by the way
commenting on this and a real clinic and
how not to frame a shot
um just at the bottom of the frame and
he goes lower and lower in the frame i
don't know what's funnier what comes out
of
andrew giuliani's mouth or the fact that
he can't even
film himself competently hi my fellow
americans today is my fellow americans
not just my fellow new yorkers
as you may have heard recently a few few
minutes ago my father's law license was
suspended
law by the new york state first
appellate division of the supreme court
now the five judges that ruled on it
judge rolando acosta judge diane renwick
oh sally manzar davis
daniel sorry judge judith gishi
and judge barbara kaepernick all five of
them are democrats
three of which were appointed by andrew
cuomo
ultimately democrats with zero
republicans on there again
this is just unbelievable to see just
how politicized
all of this has become i am infuriated
by all this and any
american that believes in an independent
justice system
this is going after one of president
trump's closest
allies that's exactly what this is did
he say president strump
is and any american that doesn't believe
that they are just biased
it is oh this is unacceptable and
i stand by my father he did everything
ultimately
by the book and the fact how would he
know that anyway
if there would be this politicization
in our justice department is discussing
it is a cancer
that needs to be cut out and it needs to
be cut out right now
thank you for listening stay tuned i'll
have more statements later in the day
yes and very powerful statements
certainly coming from him let's see in
fact if he made any other statements
um no that was four hours ago we've not
heard from him
oh he did an interview on this uh just
the truth show let's listen to just a
little bit of that
table it's very similar to the policies
that we're bringing to the table
in our gubernatorial race which is a
year out but ultimately his in the next
four and a half months he keeps talking
is he in a server room what is he doing
he seems to be i've never seen
is he just on break from his job as an
i.t guy this is weird
about how he's going to clean up the
streets the great thing about curtis is
he started the program called the
guardian angels in the latest excuse me
jenna i've got to upgrade to the latest
version of linux here before i get a
blue screen of death
when the government was doing nothing
about crime and crime was just
spiking and spiking and spiking and he
went in there
with his organization which is now i
think in 15 different countries
in four different continents around the
world um and he helped to clean up
subway crime by just having unarmed
volunteers on what
it's like what is he even talking about
okay so that's that uh president
strump put out a statement about this
not going
in the direction of rudy i don't know
was he
i think he was getting us water uh but i
don't really know who that is
trump instead saying can you believe
that
new york wants to strip rudy a great
american patriot
of his law license because he's been
fighting what has already been proven to
be a fraudulent election
the greatest oh hold on and i should
even have uh
do i have my fraud oh no i don't that's
what i'm missing i'm missing all of my
fraud
drops that's too bad uh the greatest
mayor in the history of new york city
the eliot ness of his generation one of
the greatest crime fighters our
capital c country has ever known and
this is what the
capital r capital l radical left does to
him
all of new york is out of control crime
is at an all-time high it's nothing but
a
witch hunt and they should be ashamed
of themselves take back america he says
people are flushing toilets 10 times
15 times we're looking very strongly at
sinks and showers
exactly um so that's that there is uh
there is the latest from donald trump
about this
and then here is stephen bannon former
trump strategist and breitbart
propagandist
he's he's saying they must be really
afraid not only of rudy giuliani
but also mike lindell that's an
interesting interpretation of the events
okay new york supreme court looks like
they suspended rudy giuliani's law
license to practice in new york and get
the great mayor on the evening
on our afternoon show at five o'clock
this is obviously outrageous this is now
it's five o'clock in the east now if
anybody knows where i could maybe find
what
he's referring to if rudy is on with
steve bannon live right now
i would love to check that out so please
let if that's going on let me know where
i could find it
how intimidated they are rudy giuliani
mike lindell all of it they're coming
they're intimidated by rudy and a guy
who sells pillows and and uh
yeah that's that's strange direction
right but
fear not okay by the way you had a good
thing why are they fear mike lindell
yeah i don't i don't think they do um
and i don't think suspending
rudy's law license has anything to do
with uh with with fearing
mike lindell so that's the latest from
steve bannon
um and i guess nobody knows if that is
live
let's see steve bannon
war room live let me see if i can find
that
bannon's war room i heart radio
there's an ep this is not a joke earlier
today
bannon published something called the
pillow hour
episode 1046 the pillow
hour part 2 with mike lindell and scott
mineo
watch on the web warroom.org
let's see if we can find something live
here
no that's earlier god this is i have
i have an ad blocker on that's what's
crazy oh hold on america's voice live
let's see what this is about
could we get the audio on somehow when i
go over to the audio thing it disappears
are you guys seeing that oh here it is
manufacturing supply chains
it's got to come back if the
corporations don't like it tough
you're going to bring it back okay and
you've got to have an infrastructure
built that faces that
let me talk about they say the 47
billion is going to net 100 billion
the hundred billion is going to come out
of you the audience got that it's coming
out of you
the the 24 hours not coming out of
michael bloomberg
not coming out of mark zuckerberg right
it's coming out of
the deplorables right are you steve
bannon are you just like
jumping on my best lines 20 24
24 billionaires with fifth only paid 15
billion dollars of taxes correct dr
peter navarro over the last five years
i learned everything about that from you
it's like they all worked for a
billionaire who didn't pay nearly enough
taxes but now their topic is bill
are they seriously saying the pr they're
now on billionaires aren't paying enough
taxes
what uh how could they possibly go to
that after they both worked for trump
and by the way are you this is crazy in
the bottom right they have a picture and
picture
of the ardet happening in arizona right
now where they're looking for
bamboo fibers and uh that that
spicy chili sauce leftovers and just any
sign that the
ballots may have been tampered with um
breadings that may have been
inappropriate like where for example
potato flour was used instead of normal
flour
all these things they're looking at
really really closely
in arizona so anyway we'll keep an eye
on this if rudy
giuliani does appear on this program let
me know
because i would definitely want to go to
that all right now let me get to
people's super chats because
super chats are completely off the rails
i do want to say thank you to victoria
trosh who just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
as well as mo money mo problems who just
signed up for a website membership
using the exclusive coupon code cold
feet crowder
cold feet crowder today as many of you
saw we celebrated an incredibly
uh unique event earlier this week
where there was a confrontation of
stephen crowder
oh no sam cedar and it was it was very
very entertaining so we have a cold feet
crowder coupon code
in honor of that supposedly some of the
ballots were well done
and that's suspicious because trump's
the only guy who who
asks for stuff uh well done
and so that is definitely a red flag you
wouldn't go past
medium plus if there was any sense to
what was taking place there
i do want to say thank you to dope tipt
as well as sin pre
for the twitch prime subscriptions as
well as
raquelita fuentes new members
8 9 and 10
today let me now run through some of
these super chats i
apologize i uh have fallen
fallen behind on these perfect intro
move this hi devod do you know what
space force's purpose is
i guess to protect us from aliens please
add get me a coke please to the sound
board
if we have audio of that i would do it
please put the sound bytes on the
members page
i don't know about that sir i've been
seeing lots of youtubers getting a
second or more channel why is it to have
multiple channels of income
algorithm new youtube policy i have no
idea why
we we were basically maxed out on the
main channel
so we um we we started the second
channel which you can find
at youtube.com pacman live and we did
hit that 6000 subscriber milestone
yesterday which is great
um now we're going to uh 10 000
we're going to go to six and we're going
to go to seven and then we're going to
go to 10 and keep it keep it going and
growing
so we just have too much content on the
main channel so we take
clips from these streams
and we put them on the um on the second
channel that's basically
basically the gist of it all right
okay do you ever vote for republican
presidential candidates i never have
i never have jimmy says debate
hard b geez that sounds like porn i
don't know what that means
please shout out my friend mo which in
this case is an abbreviation for monica
yes
shout out to mo appreciate that
brian says thanks for giving me the best
debating tool to use against the right
truth nicely done jimmy says
i'm live critiquing you now
debate hard you know yes
jimmy yes lucid as ever many years ago
he seemed to be smart and competent was
he
never competent or did he take a wrong
turn
um you know i don't know like was rudy
actually ever competent or was he just
better at hiding his incompetence
i can't wait to see what devin at legal
eagle has to say about this actually
devin from legal eagle will be making an
appearance on the david pakman show
let me see if i can tell you when that
is we are actually mutual fans
devin of legal eagle and david pakman of
the david pakman show
i'm just pulling up our schedule here
devin will be on with us
wait a second what's going on i thought
we had him scheduled
now i'm not even seeing it on the
calendar
hold on a second guys let's email
producer pat
hey what happened with getting
legal eagle scheduled
we i thought we had it booked
okay all right good i guess we're
standing by for uh rudy giuliani here
let's see what else we've got network
for responsible public policy
hr one for the people act this platform
sir what's your take on ranked choice
voting we have ranked choice in my city
it's given us the second choice mayoral
candidate before it got ugly
yeah i am for uh various uh systems
that um are uh
single transferable there's a bunch of
different configurations i have a bunch
of clips about this
there are ways it can be set up
so the so that the eventual winner was
not really the primary choice
for a plurality of individuals and
that's an issue we've addressed before
david do they call democrats leftists
because they're too ignorant to
differentiate between liberal centrist
or is it intentional for dramatic effect
probably both to some degree probably
both
it should be called pillow talk with
mike
mason says david do you know anything
about ivermectin being used for covet
treatment
uh i am not um i because i'm not a
medical professional i'm unable to say
too much about that
i just don't know enough about it funny
how happy jim jordan looks on far-right
news
and dominic says crossover of the
century
but i thought legal eagle can't come on
he's seeing too many people
in court that i don't even know what it
means
i don't know what you mean by that
um but i thought we were getting devin
on
i'll research that and then we'll get
back to you i also want to say thank you
to
vvxi85 v-vex i-85 for the twitch prime
subscription
remember i don't care who you give your
twitch prime subscription to
but don't leave it in jeff bezos's
pocket that's not
good make sure you're giving it to
someone if you have
an amazon prime account you get a free
twitch prime
every month and you've got to remember
to use it it doesn't renew automatically
you could certainly use it with me
but make sure you're using it we don't
want to leave that money in jeff bezos's
pocket
hayden says i'm literally right next
door to the president right now
looking forward to his speech
yeah um biden's schedule
we also have a biden event coming up
what time is that five oh very soon let
me let me get that going hold on white
house youtube
channel i almost forgot about that
here it is so as we stand by for rudy
giuliani
we've also got this event i'll just
leave the audio up so that when it
starts we'll see it
and uh they're continuing the pillow
promos let's see what's what could he
possibly be saying about it let's see
check it out mypillar.com promo code war
room take action action action this is
the entire
agency their sales and discounts on
every item but this is the big one 109
congratulations sir you just won the
election pack six pack of towels and
these towels are incredible i can tell
you okay
rudy giuliani here we go greatest mayor
of new york ever had here we go mass put
the mob away put the wall street mob
away
cleaned up new york made it uh the
greatest it was the greatest in the
world but it was a
steep decline turned around no crime
prosperous people happy
living together that rudy giuliani a
fierce defender of the president
a man has been he on now our uh 2020 man
of the year in the war room
and an incredible individual i'm
bringing his uh his lawyer judge
leventhal judge leventhal
msnbc are dancing on rudy's grave today
can you tell us exactly what happened he
got the
temporarily uh disbanded from
or banned can't practice law in new york
state what exactly happened and how
serious is this
um the mayor giuliani was interimly
suspended pending a full disciplinary
hearing
right and and that's what uh
by order of the appellate division first
department
which is the intermediate appellate
court in manhattan and bronx
crystal clear okay in in
in in layman's terms what does that mean
normally guys that do this are these
guys like the lawyers are a drug addict
stealing out of escrow accounts
exactly essentially reprobates rudy
giuliani is one of the greatest
living americans that's done more for
his country than
virtually anybody is is he now
considered are they treating him like
they treat lawyers who are basically
if you're just joining us in the bottom
right of your screen you see what's
happening in the arizona election audit
very important meanwhile we're hearing
from rudy's lawyer about why
he can't practice law in new york
anymore well the
an interim suspension is usually uh
utilized
for someone who has uh un
has uncontroverted evidence or an
admission
that they stole clients money or from or
from their escrow account or that
someone had a a substance abuse problem
which is uncontroverted
and there's evidence that they
repeatedly neglected various clients
of representation and that they would be
a present public danger
to the practice of law so unfortunately
the appellate division because of uh
statements that uh the mayor
has made has suspended him
similarly yes as they would these other
individuals beautiful
and he hasn't had a hearing yet and we
are
hopeful and we believe that when
he has this hearing uh he will be
reinstated as a valued member of the
legal profession that he has served so
well
in his many capacities in many
capacities for so many years
well he is a valued member of the legal
profession he's a valued member of this
country he's one of the great leaders in
the world
uh rudy giuliani by the way in the
subtext there it was statements he made
in michigan in in
the presentation of statements he made
on the show right where he was talking
about facts off of peter navarro's
analysis
and others and 3 000 affidavits 3 000
affidavits that he had
and now you see i didn't realize bannon
was fully in on the voter fraud thing
that's this appellate court suspended
his ability to make a living and tried
to humiliate and shame on the greatest
living americans that sacrificed
more first country virtually than
anybody to defend the city he loves to
defend
the little guy in the city loves defend
the little guy that gets crushed by
these wall street mafia
and the real mafia that's what we're
doing because he made statements
in defense of an illegitimate election
that we know
now is illegitimate because the receipts
are coming out in arizona and other
places
is that why they suspended his license
sir
they are of the view that the statements
that he made
were proven to be untrue sure and
and he knowingly made those statements
and sir you're on the cover of that
position number one uh the mayor
should be given a hearing and an
assuming arguendo any statement
may not be true he did not knowingly
know that that statement was untrue it's
based on
affidavits it's based on statements
it's based on experts uh opinions
that were given to him he didn't just
invent that over
from uh whole cloth
judge leventhal you're a good man what's
the next step in this we gotta do we go
to biden
hello everybody who's this guy is this
new summer
oh i know everybody's been waiting such
a long time
and guess what's still to come
we want to welcome president joe biden
to the great state of north carolina
we're going to go with this then we'll
go back
we want to thank him for providing
strong
coordinated sensible strategic
national leadership out of this pandemic
we want to thank him for helping us with
testing
getting us vaccine in a reliable and
predictable way
and partnering with governors both
democratic and republican
across the country setting up sites
and getting shots in arms
thank god for these vaccines
wow what about scientists
bank scientific ah research
thanks perseverance for these stunningly
effective life-saving vaccines
that are allowing us to gather right
here today
right and
thank you to president biden
for setting setting the example
of strong compassionate leadership
for this country and putting people
first
now in north carolina all of us together
are working to emerge from this pandemic
stronger than before
and with president biden's leadership we
have
american rescue plan funds to help us
make
transformational changes high-speed
internet access
waste water and water infrastructure
housing
education child care we can do this
thing and this pandemic has been shining
a light
on challenges that we have already faced
now we can do something about it
and in north carolina so we're waiting
for biden but we're keeping an eye on if
and when rudy will be joining steve
bannon we'll monitor both
uncharted waters during this pandemic we
used
science and data to make the hard
decisions and with our largest states
north carolina is among
the lowest in deaths and job loss
per capita that's a good thing we've
done things right
and with our vaccines we've administered
almost nine
million doses we've gotten about 55
of our adult population with at least
one shot and about 82 percent of 65 and
over
with at least one shot but we are still
not where we need to to be
and that's why we are here today
that's where you guys come in that's
where you guys come in
you're going to go out into these
communities
talking with people you will have the
power to save
lives you will have the power to
persuade
the hesitant you can tell them about
your own story
with vaccines you can listen to them
you can let them know that you care
you can let them know that they just
aren't protecting themselves when they
get a vaccine
but protecting their family their
friends
and other people and you can tell them
you too
can win one million
you just dollars your vaccine it's like
gambling and for those 12 through 17 you
can win
a full college scholarship we had a
drawing yesterday we're going to be
making an announcement soon there's
three more to go
so let them know we will
get this done we will get it done
one call one visit one house
one conversation one person
one shot at a time together
we will get enough people vaccinated to
put this pandemic behind us
for good
a strong hype train happening right now
[Applause]
what do they say all right we've got two
people coming up here
that you're gonna love in addition
to you and me there are two people
coming up who are going to tell us
what else we're going to do we have a
north carolinian
who has come back she's just finished
her first year at princeton
university and she is back
helping our communities and she's
working
to get shots in arms big time when i see
students
like her stepping up it makes me know
that north carolina is going to get
through this
even stronger than before and i'm
excited about that
so let me introduce to you
our very own ivy jones who is going to
introduce to you
the president of the united states of
america joe biden
wow if you're just joining us so we are
standing by for rudy giuliani
on steve bannon's program we're about to
hear from joe biden let me make sure
everybody who's been supporting the
stream does get a thank you
bobo fetra as well as josh rambo
flat chileans as well as green
supreme stream have signed up via twitch
sumizu and zero kiwi
frito baggins and joseph's captures
spamosino dom's dad
ammo in all have signed up that's nine
putting us at 20. we're about to hear
from joe biden remember you can also use
that insane coupon code
cold feet crowder on my website which is
just
out of this world crazy biden perfectly
framed through the teleprompter just
couldn't be a perfect more perfect shot
today
that princeton university like many
campuses across our country
would be shifting to a virtual format
while i was disappointed at this less
than typical start to my college career
it did not outdo the devastation brought
about by the pandemic
as someone with a father in the army and
a mother with a serious respiratory
condition
i knew that our physical distance was
needed
because the health of our family was at
stake i
made sacrifices to increase the odds
that my loved ones would live to see
another day even when that meant intense
feelings of isolation
i watched helpless as coba 19 cases and
fatalities began to climb
in north carolina the only home i've
known for 18 years
this state has taken the stress of over
a million coven 19
cases and more than 13 000 north
carolinians have lost their lives to
this terrible illness
now that we have safe and reliable
vaccines available to us
it is imperative that we do our part to
stop the spread
of cover 19. as we usher in this new
phase of the pandemic
we should rejoice in the ability to see
our friends and family again
but not forget that the pandemic is not
over
it won't be until we all do our part and
get vaccinated
as i stand here before you there are
over 400 people
hospitalized in north carolina fighting
coba 19.
that number may seem insignificant but
each one of those
400 people our family friends partners
and
heroes to their communities each of
those people
belong to the greater fabric of this
state and their struggle
should not be understated if the
pandemic has reinforced to anything it
is that ability and health life
is not insured to anyone despite what we
would like to believe
to receive the coba 19 vaccine is to
honor the over 400 people hospitalized
at this very moment
to receive this vaccine is to honor you
your community
and to honor the gift of another day
many of us celebrated when it was our
turn to get vaccinated and pledged to do
whatever it took to ensure we kept our
community safe
we remembered what it was like last year
unable to leave the house
hug our friends or relatives and we
wanted to make sure
that the sacrifices we made during that
time were worth it
right and although i am now fully
vaccinated those sacrifices
still mean the world that is why i'm so
delighted to be here with governor
cooper and president biden today
so i can have the ability to join with
them in encouraging north carolinians of
all
backgrounds to get vaccinated being here
today
alongside our leaders emphasizes how
crucial this vaccine is
and keeping communities healthy and
creating a promising future
it is my honor to introduce one of the
leaders ensuring that our communities
stay safe not just in north carolina but
across the country
please welcome president joseph r biden
i i'm gonna
[Applause]
look that old i uh
you're by the way you're in the midst of
uh you're in the presence of a
one hell of an individual i want you all
to know about
come on man
he's always there when people need help
and he particularly focuses on people
we're left behind reverend barber
thanks for all you do rev ivy uh
thank you for their induction you know
uh definitely more energy in the room
today
you know uh i uh i think i thank
everyone here
at the green road community center for
hosting us
governor cooper my good friend great
governor but the most important thing
he's a man of enormous integrity
i know he really is
you're doing an incredible job i'm lucky
to have you as a partner gov
and as we uh as we move along here look
you know uh the main thing i want to do
is start off with
the way you should never start off are
there you have any chairs out there
well if you have a chair sit don't stand
for me
i i don't know why i love it when he
tells people i was getting to feel
really guilty man
i said that a while ago as the press
will tell you about
a year ago i said why did everybody sit
down and somebody in the front said
i don't have a damn seat that's why i
don't want to get in trouble
thank you i thought you didn't have any
seats so i
really feel guilty folks look um
uh it's great to be with mayor baldwin
of raleigh and
and mayor mayor schull durham
and joined by a proud native son of
north carolina
the administrator of the epa
in washington d.c michael reagan where
are you michael
i'm always worried
i'm always worried when i come back to
north carolina michael's with me that
the governor's going to take him back
but i need him look folks
he's doing one heck of a job at epa and
if you want to talk about health
think about the environment think about
what's happened being done but we're
changing an epa
and it makes a big deal it's also uh
it's also out there across the state
encouraging people to get vaccinated as
well
i wanted to come to raleigh to thank
everyone in this room for everything
you're doing to get your community
vaccinated it matters it matters
you're saving lives that's not hyperbole
let me remind everybody
we lost 600
000 dead in america
in about a year that's more than every
life
lost in world war one world war
ii the vietnam war
iraq iran across the board
afghanistan more lives lost in a year
than every major war in the 20th century
in the 21st century
and guess what folks the main lives lost
all around the world in america i might
say this is not
i didn't plan on saying this but i'm
going to anyway
we have an obligation in the united
states of america
to live up to who we are america
is the only unique nation we're the only
nation
formed based on an idea an idea
not an ethnicity not an ideology not
idea we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men and women are
created equal etc
well here's the deal here's the deal
there are over a hundred countries in
the world
that have no capacity to help themselves
right now none
people desperate for vaccines all over
the world and here twenty percent of the
country's like
nah yeah yeah in the first hundred days
over 60 million doses of vaccine for
americans
i went to europe she meet what they call
the g7 and then with nato and then with
the eu
and i promised the united states the
remainder of this year
and the first half of next year is going
to provide
a billion doses to the rest of the world
a billion dollars
a half a billion of those will be done
between now and january
and the first half of next year point
being
i wanted the nation to reflect what you
all reflect
everyone in this room there's everything
i want to thank you for all you're doing
but the rest of the world is in trouble
as well
we have to look out for one another we
really do
and what you're doing here go back to
the united states
non-profits directing folks to where to
go
houses of worship opening on-site
vaccination
for congregants my friend reverend
barber is here as i said had
countless faith leaders who who are
truly
doing god's work college students
providing rides for seniors
it's what's happening in america is what
america is all about
that's what the rest of the world is
looking at are we what we advertise
ourselves to be
because of people like you here in
raleigh and communities across america
who are going to win this fight look at
the progress we made so far
today 66 percent of all american adults
have gotten at least one shot
that includes 87 percent of all seniors
of all colors 75 percent of adults ages
40 and up
have gotten a shot and 70 percent of
those
aged 30 and up nationwide we're seeing
the lowest number of daily cases and
deaths
since the first day of the pandemic
and we've built equity into the heart of
the vaccination program
i put together a vaccination team headed
by a really bright guy
we put together a group of 23 doctors
and what they did was we had one doc who
does nothing but deal with equity
access for people there's a reason why
it's been harder to get
african-americans initially
to get vaccinated because they're used
to being experimented on
the tuskegee airmen and others
people have memories people have long
memories
it's awful hard as well to get
latinx vaccinated as well why no not
latinos they're worried that they'll be
vaccinated and deported not a fan of the
latinx
thing something that governor
cooper has been totally focused on is
making sure we get as many people
vaccinated particularly people
who don't have access to health care
usually who don't have
ordinary don't have doctors family
physicians etc
73 percent of the shots administered at
community health centers
through the federal program we have and
more than 58 percent of the shots
administered in federally run
vaccination sites
have gone to people of color it makes a
gigantic difference
and across the nation people of color
accounted for more than
half of all the vaccinations in the last
month
the more we close the racial gap and
vaccination rates the more lives we can
save
and if i can
man and if i could pause for one second
that's why i've called for spending
billions of dollars at nih focusing on
new ways to deal with obesity
diabetes alzheimer and cancer
focused just on those diseases money
that
private drug companies don't have the
money to invest in
or the inclination to because guess what
in most black communities across america
and hispanic communities
how many stores have fresh vegetables
how many stores have i go down the list
it matters the health condition a person
enters this fight over makes a big
difference
as to what in fact is going to be able
to be done here in north carolina
my administration has provided 105
million dollars
from the emergency map federal emergency
management agency fema
to help get people vaccinated working
with the governor and the mayors and
county officials across the state
there are 240 personnel in the tar heel
state
just to put the needle in somebody's arm
this has been a gigantic
a gigantic logistical challenge not just
in north carolina but all across america
more than 660 national guard members
have supported
the kova 19 response here in north
carolina
over in greensboro we stood up the
federal vaccination site
that alone has administered 135
000 shots the governor and i visited one
of the mobile units you're deploying
to meet the people where they live a
result of these efforts
statewide case deaths are down over 90
percent in the last five months
all of this is great news but here's the
deal
for all the progress we made as a
country hospitalizations of the deaths
are down drastically
in places where people are getting
vaccinated right the data couldn't be
clear if you're vaccinated
if you're vaccinated you're safe you've
been you are still at risk of getting
seriously ill or dying
if you in fact have not been vaccinated
that's just a fact
and this new dangerous variant continues
to emerge
it's now the most common variant
in america in here and unvaccinated
people
are incredibly vulnerable this is a
serious concern with what experts call
the delta
variant it is not only
according to the cdc that can
between 10 and 20 of all cases in the
last two weeks
have been the delta variant dr fauci has
made it clear he and my wife have been
traveling the country to make this case
that it's more easily transmittable this
delta variant
potentially deadlier and especially
dangerous for young people
for young people he says it's the
greatest threat to our fight to beat
coven 19.
but the good news is we have a solution
the science is clear the best way to
protect yourself against the virus and
its variance
is to be fully vaccinated it works
it's free it's safe it's easy
it's convenient over 150 million america
uh oh
looks like it's this particular feed
because our bannon feed is still going
beautifully the greatest threat to our
fight
to beat coven 19. but the good news is
we have a solution
the science is clear the best way to
protect yourself against the virus and
this variance
is to be fully vaccinated is it going to
freeze again it works
it's free it's safe it's easy
it's convenient over 150 million america
oh boy yeah
something may be wrong with the feed
if i refresh again and it goes right to
the same spot again as opposed to live
he says it's the greatest threat towards
oh yeah to beat cover 19.
man maybe if i go back and then hit live
he says it's the greatest threat to our
fight
but the good news is we have a solution
we may have to abandon it
let's see if uh bannon's getting rudy on
which was really the point of of today
reports about ufos why now what's in it
what does it mean for you all next in
the war room
okay so they're going to ufo stuff next
i guess
um let's try going live one more time
here
it's easy it's convenient
over 150 million left in uber
said okay between the time was last
night to july 4th
they'll provide a ride free to and from
they'll wait and take you back home
thousands of pharmacies are offering no
appointment walk-in vaccinations
more than 1 400 pharmacies
are in north carolina that do that
rights they've already administered 2.2
million shots
these pharmacies many of them are open
24 hours
on fridays so go tomorrow if you've not
gotten it done or when you're going out
knocking on doors tell them is that true
24 hours only on friday 24 hours
majority of these these drug stores are
open
get it done get it done and get it down
to their convenience and if you still
have questions
that's okay talk to people
who you know have gotten the shot that's
what you guys are out going to be doing
knocking on doors
yeah good talk to your doctor or health
provider
if you don't have one physicians know
it's the right choice to get vaccinated
to protect themselves their patients and
their communities
and listen to north carolina's own dr
kizzy covert
you know from from hurdle mills just
about an hour north of here
she's a scientist at nih that i met
several weeks ago
who helped develop the covet 19 vaccine
a vaccine was developed after
decades of research under republican and
democratic administrations
as i said i met her earlier this year
during a tour of nih vaccine research
center
where this all happened she's incredible
folks there's no reason to leave
yourself vulnerable to the deadly virus
for one single day more and as they say
in my church i'm preaching to the choir
i know
but the television is recording this
make the case let people know getting
vaccinated
is not only maybe going to save their
lives but save their mother their father
their child their son
their daughter their co-worker so please
please get vaccinated
and let everyone do our part let's
everyone do it this weekend
we'll be hosting another nationwide
canvassing event where volunteers like
you're going to knock on doors and talk
to friends and neighbors to help finish
the job of getting
america vaccinated to join that effort i
say to the people watching this
because these people have already joined
the effort to join that effort
please visit we can do
this.hhs.governor.gov excuse me
we can do this dot
hhs.gov sign up
get involved we can do this we really
can't do this
come on man let me close where i began
to all of you here today we're about to
head out and canvas your communities
thank you from the bottom of my heart i
genuinely mean it
but just listen again to ivy
graduated from apex friendship high
just finished her first year in school
she's defending her summer doing door to
door going door to help get people
vaccinated to stay safe and i'll bet
what she had to say when asked
is what a lot of you think as well she
said quote
i hope you don't mind my repeating this
ivy but
she said quote reaching out and giving
back to the community is everything
i like to say i don't dream of having a
dream job or a dream career
but i dream of truly helping people in
the best way i can
that's my life goal
this can be among one of those important
things you do
i really mean it and again
remember i think you're probably the
least ones i have to remember remember
six hundred thousand
plus americans have died
six hundred thousand plus
americans have died
this delta variant you know there's
going to be others as well
you know what's going to happen we've
got to get our young people vaccinated
so talk to those moms when you knock on
the door
tell them about tell them about
why it's so important to get their
children
you may remember i got widely criticized
when i suggested we'd keep dropping the
age of people eligible for vaccinations
not by me it's been based on the science
i didn't do anything based on a whim
the science the tests show that
and what's going to happen here i
predict
as soon as we go from temporary approval
to permanent approval which just takes
time it's not that it doesn't think it's
there
it's going to increase the number of
people willing to move as well
about a third of people said about a
third of people who are currently
hesitant said they'd get vaccinated
after
the full approval rather than emergency
approval all got the whole world in
front of you
and uh you know it's because of uh
it's because of people like ivy and all
of you why i have so much faith in the
future
i'm not being you know you notice i've
been under
fairly criticized for being optimistic
i've been fairly criticized because i
think we can actually pull people
together i ran when i ran for president
i ran for three reasons i said one was
restore the soul of america
just basic decency looking out for me
[Applause]
by the way for whoever is saying 36 000
people die in traffic every day
no it's 36 000 per year not not per day
it doesn't i mean
we can still compare whatever you want
to compare but let's at least do the
right numbers guys
folks it's about time to build the
economy
from the middle up and out and from the
middle class up
that's what we have to do folks
let's really let this be the summer of
joy and freedom
the summer of george let's celebrate the
fourth of july with the independence
from the virus
we can get this done congratulations sir
you just won the election
we really can do it but you know what
i said the third reason i was running
was to unify the country
well folks
it's never been as divided as it is
today
never been as divided as is today since
a civil war
and folks is such a waste of talent
such a waste of time
and the rest of the world is looking at
us
the rest of the world is wondering
whether or not can we really
lead the world again
the last four years have been
devastating to our leadership around the
world
that's for sure it's true and god bless
us but here's the way we lead united
states
i always lead those who lead better than
i
and others they lead by example
and the example is twofold and i'll end
with this
one it's making sure we do everything
in our power to walk that extra mile
to knock on that door to pick up the
phone
to actually really really strong 50
super chat from
umberto here i would look at that really
strongly
why it's so important
let them know because people
people respond to individual
relationships
even new ones i got it my brother got it
my sister got it i took
my daughter and she got it etc
and secondly let the world know
that when it comes down to
life-saving initiatives no matter where
they
are where but they come from us
we should share them with the world the
whole world
we're even given some of these vaccines
to nations that are not our friends
because the people are not the ones who
are not our friends
chambers so folks is
what we can do as i said
i have faith in your generation the
reason i'm so optimistic
is because you're the most incredible
generation
in american history and not be a
solicitous
number one you're the least prejudiced
generation
in history true number one
[Applause]
you volunteer the most any other
generation
including my vaulted generation of the
60s
you know i mean it we're proud of what
we did
but you volunteer number three
you're the best educated generation in
the history of america
and i believe our dealing with equity
is only the beginning as it relates to a
vaccine
the first executive order i signed was
insisting that every one of my cabinet
members
focus on racial equity because
we have a tie we have a chance
we have a chance to make significant
change
in this country it's going to come from
what you guys do
i really mean it i can't thank you
enough sorry to take so much of your
time but
god bless you all may god protect our
troops thank you thank you thank you
what an event
there he goes
and off he goes
all right so there we go uh joe biden
with a very very
strong statement there uh as far as
vaccination is concerned we are standing
by
still for uh rudy giuliani who's had his
law license suspended by the state of
new york
um on the steve bannon show do people
know if this is an hour show or a
two-hour show because if it's an hour
show it ends in a minute
um so we'll keep an eye on this
we'll keep an eye on that momentarily
okay
um and then there was one other thing i
did want to look at while we
while we wait oh hold on let me say
thank you to a few other people
thanks to vent dew as well as
churro de french wicked beats
and ones comp oh as well as jimmy 10
pins for the twitch prime subscriptions
i really appreciate that putting us at
25
and remember that today is the last day
and maybe maybe saturday if i end up
streaming the trump rally
but we're getting very very close to the
absolute last day
for using the coupon code cold
feet crowder at joinpakman.com
oh no sam cedar we're getting to the
very very end of that uh celebrating
the incredible events of this week with
stephen crowder
and uh sam cedar sam who that's for you
to find out that's for you to find out
when you use the coupon code cold fee
crowder
um i want to say thank you to oh look we
got a raid from someone from
book smarts book smarts welcome to 140
people from book smarts
um is that like a book review channel
that sounds interesting
i was actually gonna do my list of books
um in fact while we're waiting we could
even do
um i could even tell you the most recent
stuff i picked up
let's see i'm just pulling up my my book
list
just endless lists and lists and lists
if i have time before bannon comes back
so i just grabbed oh i'm gonna read this
on my my vacation
um hells angels by hunter thompson
highly recommended
i did by going clear by lawrence wright
because i just read lawrence wright's
pandemic novel the end of october
recently
i'm going to read going clear about
scientology
i'm reading nick bilton's hatching
twitter about the origins or the oranges
depending on your preference
of twitter a 1491 new revelations
that's a great book that has been it's
been highly recommended to me i've read
the first 10 pages
it's about pre-1492 americas
and then from the standpoint of um
from from the standpoint of what we
would call i guess
a fiction i'm currently reading infinite
jest
by um david foster wallace
and i also grabbed a um another one
of robert ludlum's books i've read the
the bourne trilogy they're just fun you
know i'm going on vacation and it's just
robert ludlum's stuff is fantastic and
and we are going to
uh get a very strong review of that very
soon okay
so it looks as though bannon's show is
over this is jenna ellis who got
corvid from rudy herself and petty never
trump mentality
over issues that really matter like
election integrity
several prominent republicans and of
course president trump have endorsed
elise stefanik as cheney's replacement
but all right so i'm guessing okay so
people are telling me that tonight on uh
newsmax rudy giuliani is going to appear
i want to say thank you to patricia
palin oh my goodness patricia palin
has just signed up at joinpackman.com
new member number 26 today i appreciate
that patricia
um guys by the way i i'm i'm joking
around when i say
rudy gave jenna ellis covid through
flatulence it's conceivable that he did
but i'm not aware that that's actually a
method of transmission
i think he gave it to her through
through respiratory transmission
it's just a joke it's just a joke um
everybody relax all right and then
here's the last thing i want to go over
okay
this is really i don't know how many
people will be interested in this i came
across this yesterday
and i have been in a rabbit hole of this
stuff as many of you know
other than the david pakman show i am
known for
when i was 17 years old and i worked in
sales at the now defunct circuit city
i was in the top 200 sales people
nationally
and i had to get a parental permission
to go to the top salespeople
uh celebration in orlando florida
and so i'm just fascinated by sales and
i have a lot of friends who work in car
sales
i came across this channel steve
richards and
this guy i guess teaches other car sales
people
training uh sales training he teaches
car sales techniques to other sales
people
and as i watch this it's like this i
would never work with this guy
and really what i came away with from
watching this and i want to watch it
with some of you guys now
is how can an actual dealership that
still has to badger people
and trick them with insurance with uh
with with oh i can lower your payment
but then you're
you know the reason you're doing it is
giving them an 84-month loan and all
this stuff
when we in with tesla and other
increasingly brands
you go online and you just pick the
pricing is completely transparent and
you click order
like how can how can a dealership with a
horrible experience compete with that
anyway
check it let's just dive into this okay
i love this stuff like who would buy
from this guy
all right we've worked hard to put
together a fair proposal however we
understand that you're the judge and
jury when it comes to fair
we also know what happens if you don't
think it's fair you get up out of that
seat you walk back through our two front
doors you jump in the car you hope you
never drive again
and you leave that's why we made it fair
msrp 25030 now the splash guards this
will be the best investment you make
over the next four or five years this
will keep your vehicles
paint intact can you imagine can can you
i mean okay
at least splash guards is a thing where
like rust proofing and rain coating and
and all this stuff i mean it's it this
brings back memories to when i used to
shop for cars
in dealerships and it's just a nightmare
on both sides
it will double triple quadruple
the cost when it comes to you getting
money back by selling it or trading it
the pin stripes make it distinctive
there's your total
investment our discount is 750 dollars
your trade we love it we'll buy it for
15
950. please recognize this when you
trade the car to us
this is the amount of cash that stays in
your pocket instead of going to the
state of georgia
right so you add this to this and that's
1725.
um there's the difference doc fee filing
fee
your taxes miscellaneous dealer fees
dealer overcharge fee
and dealer scam fee let's add it all up
together
after you pay off there's what you're
financing now
recognize this each time you decrease
your term
you save yourself a pile of money the
difference between
this and this can be over three thousand
dollars in interest that you save
each time you increase your term
your payment goes down so with your
initial investment of a thousand dollars
your payments 629 to 639 that payment
may look high but here's what it does
for you saves you three grand
and it makes us a bunch of money
allows you to pay it off quicker you
build equity faster
yeah by the way you build equity it's
like
okay yeah when you pay less interest
you are paying more principal but the
idea of a vehicle
as an equity builder it's a depreciating
asset right
so at its base this concept of building
equity in your own car it this is not
the right way to think of vehicles
it's that and and you know a lot of
people who are more
personal finance savvy would understand
that you have the freedom to trade or
sell it sooner
at 72 this payment is
comfortable and flexible it's
comfortable because it's
200 bucks less it's flexible because you
can always pay it off early without
penalty and enjoy the same benefits you
got up here
this payment right here is the best of
both worlds the payment's significantly
less than it would be at 48. you save
more money
it's like a sort of this this bowl of
porridge is too hot
this bowl of porridge is too cold this
one's just right it's like do we even
want porridge
is porridge uh nutritious it's just like
a total misdirect
72 circle an initial payment that works
best for you
okay that right there we'll get you
civic ready for delivery no i want
eighteen thousand so much money
okay carol
it is my honor to meet you mr president
where is that coming
and um i enjoyed very much our
conference that's not even live sorry
guys
for your trade is evidence that you are
a perfectly normal human being
everybody that trades a car in once more
for the trade
i want more for a trade so that's not a
problem we understand completely
other than the trade value everything
else works fine nothing else stops you
from taking the uh
civic home today correct okay well
so that's i'm guessing that they have a
name for that technique called like
isolation maybe where
before you'll even talk about the trade
you want to preempt any further
discussions and then he'll just talk to
you about the trade you won't be
convinced but he'll claim you are
and he'll be like you said there was
nothing other than the trade so we're
ready to move forward now
you're gonna go i don't believe it but
when i show you the math
you're gonna discover that we're not
that far apart
okay yeah you won 18 and quite frankly
that's a great number
we hope that the vehicle can be worth 18
or even a little bit more but we've got
to put a ton of money into this car to
get it to be worth 18 we're gonna put
five
six thousand dollars into it research
you've done is good
we'll buy it for 16 950. do me a favor
carol i'll take 18 000
all right anyway so we don't have to
watch the whole thing but i was down a
rabbit hole on this uh yesterday on
youtube
like i who could who would possibly buy
a car from this guy it's just
wild that anybody would do that my
approach when i was
when i was in sales was to do basically
the opposite of all of this guy's
instincts
and it worked really well for me it
worked really really well for me
am i streaming on saturday i have every
intention i have absolutely every
intention of streaming the trump rally
on saturday night now
we are going to be starting our vacation
which will carry us through
the 4th of july of 2023 that's a joke by
the way no
we're starting our fourth of july
vacation after tomorrow's show
and um i don't know the quality
of my internet on saturday i'm gonna i'm
gonna be on the road
but i really want to try to stream that
uh
that rally my vacation's not really
going to have started yet so
every intention is to stream the rally i
think the rally's at eight eastern
if my internet's good enough i'll
probably start at
7 15 p.m eastern on saturday
uh if the internet's no good then you
know what that'll just be it we won't be
able to do it
but um that is the planned next
stream and remember if you have more
audio
drops that i should have uh available
get those in because we absolutely love
those
looking at that very strongly looking
super strongly at that
appreciate everybody joining me today
and i'll see you very soon